corona hotspot haben mehr als 2000
menschen sind in dieser stadt derzeit in
quarantäne
grund für diese corona welle ist eine
große hochzeit jetzt reagiert die stadt
erste feiern sind verboten und mir
zugeschaltet ist michael engelbert in
hamm
ja ich sage das gerade es gibt jetzt in
hamm erste konsequenzen was genau soll
passieren und wie reagieren die menschen
darauf ja guten tag patricia also wir
stehen tatsächlich auch vor einem der
ausbruchs punkte hier in einem hammer
industriegebiet die veranstaltungshallen
layla da hat diese hannah feier einen
junggesellinnen veranstaltung
stattgefunden
zwei von den 45 teilnehmerinnen waren
der korona positiv allerdings ist das
leider erst später aufgefallen als es
dann die große hochzeit über drei tage
verteilt gab
aktuell sind hier in der stadt wohl 200
personen mit corona infiziert der
oberbürgermeister und ziga petermann ist
auch ziemlich angefressen
man erwägt eventuell auch
strafrechtliche und zivilrechtliche
konsequenzen
ein problem ist natürlich dass zum
beispiel alleine von den 200.000 unter
quarantäne stehenden schon 800 schülern
sind man hat jetzt hier die masken
pflicht im unterricht wieder eingeführt
das heißt die schüler und schülerinnen
müssen alle wieder mal ausgetragen das
ist klar gelernt schon aber man hatte
sich natürlich gefreut dass in nrw die
masken schlicht im unterricht fällt
jetzt ist sie wieder da und natürlich
hat man hier angst vor einem zweiten
lockdown das muss man sagen dass könnten
die leute und die ja die
geschäftsbetreiber hier in der stadt
auch wohl glaube ich kaum verklappt
verkraften bisschen noch was zu haben
haben es so eine klassische durch fahr
stadt hier sind zwei große gerichtet
dass das landesarbeitsgericht und das
oberlandesgericht das gibt also ganz
ganz viele leute die einfach morgens in
die stadt rein fahren und abends wieder
raus und deshalb ist natürlich auch die
die angst hier sehr sehr groß die stadt
hat eine neue allgemeinverfügung ins
rennen gebracht und zwar dürfen sich
jetzt nur noch fünf personen öffentlich
aus zwei haushalten treffen die erste
private feiern sind abgesagt und ja wir
hoffen dass das infektionsgeschehen hier
eingedämmt werden kann allerdings ist
haben nicht der einzige corona hotspot
in emsdetten im kreis steinfurt ist
mitte der woche auf geblockter 26
mitarbeiter eines puten zerlegebetrieb
sich auch bei privaten feiern sehr
wahrscheinlich mit corona infiziert
haben da ist jetzt so dass der betrieb
geschlossen wurde
jetzt werden hygienemaßnahmen überlegt
und da müssen heute bis zum wochenende
500 personen 300 arbeiter und 200
kontaktperson getestet werden und da
hofft man natürlich auch mit verfolgung
der kontakte dass es da nicht einen
weiteren hotspot gibt sonst sehen wir
hier für nrw tatsächlich schwarz michael
vielen herzlichen dank nach hamm mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren